[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hi how are you
i'm fine that's good i see we're
speaking about science today
that's a you like that subject yes i
like science
yeah because you're a scientist so they
say
there's some interesting things that
we're going to discuss
so let's ask the lord to help us
our heavenly father thank you for
bringing us together again
we ask again please help us with the
holy spirit enlighten our minds
and bless this discussion in jesus name
amen amen
i see we're a little bit closer i can
almost
yeah we've called this one science
falsely so-called
now is there anything wrong with science
no but there's something wrong with
science falsely so called right
yes now i've always been interested in
science
i love science and i drove my
poor mother nuts because my entire room
was
full of insects and bugs and critters
and i built all kinds of things to
see what the animals do i built
tunnel ways and things out of plaster of
paris
and caught queens of ants and
put them in there and watched the
process
and i built telescopes when i was a kid
and i used to go to the library in those
days you went to the library if you
wanted books that's sort of
history right it didn't go to google and
i used to go and get all the science
books down there and i still remember
them they were
horizon books of science and
that's what i used to read when i was a
kid and people would think i'm a little
bit
crazy and i built contraptions
and got into trouble and built bombs
so science was always my thing
and i loved biology and physiology in
particular
and that was my life and let's
put it quite categorically there's
nothing wrong with science
but there's something terribly wrong
with the philosophy of science
and this is what we're talking about
here we're talking about
a type of science so
if you want to go to the bible verses
and you go to first timothy chapter 6 20
o timothy keep that which is committed
to thy trust
avoiding profane and vain babblings and
oppositions of science
so called it's sort of
a a fatherly appeal right yeah
don't get hung up and lost in
these vain babblings and if you look it
up
in the concordances then the word for
science there is
gnosis knowing
knowledge by implication knowledge
science
and of course it pertains largely to
the science of salvation and the
gnostics of course
had the idea that
christ was not divine in any other sense
then we are also
divine and if you look up
in tears concordance then it gives us a
little bit
more information knowledge
signifies in general intelligence and
understanding
the general knowledge of the christian
religion the deeper more perfect and
enlarged
knowledge of this religion such as
belongs to the more advanced
especially of things lawful and unlawful
for
christians moral wisdom such as
is seen in right living
but it also means as
we see here in strong's knowledge or
science
basically the science of salvation and
how it all
fits together but god is also
the author of general science
and the laws of thermodynamics and all
of these things
are laws that are built into
the creation and some science
violates these laws if you take the laws
of thermodynamics and you take the law
on entropy
everything tends towards disorder
then evolution is the reversal of that
law of thermodynamics because then you
have order out of chaos
that's an occult principle yes
whereas in god's word there was also
chaos but through the word it became
organized organized exactly
so there is science and there is
science and when i think back of my own
life
the science itself was
fascinating how everything works how the
physiology works how
chemicals talk to each other i loved
organic chemistry
i took it as a major in my university
career
and i love biochemistry and
biology and physiology and
how everything functions and how
how beautiful it all fits together
and when i discovered
god then it's it
suddenly blossomed yeah i was always
wondering
how scientists if they believe in god
then you can just
like you just mentioned it
elevates the science and god even more
absolutely it is a it is an
elevating experience that you cannot
describe
but you have to turn your thinking
around 180 degrees
because what you've been taught yes not
in terms of the science
but in terms of the philosophy behind
the science
and once the philosophy of science
becomes
integrated with the science itself
then you also can have reversals
and if you take the creation account
how geology sees
the phenomena in the world the
stratigraphic layers and the rocks
how they interpret them and how you
would interpret them
under a model where you use
catastrophism and the flood
they are diametrically opposed to each
other
and once you you go to the root of it
then you will find that the
interpretation that the world uses
is not even logical yeah it cannot be
logical because how can you have flat
layers
saying that they once represented the
surface of the earth
and there is no evidence of erosion
between the layers that doesn't make any
sense
and then it's also the time periods
between those layers
are millions of years so when there is
no basis for it other than
an extraneous philosophy that is
attached to something because you cannot
date these these layers and then you
have the
circular reason in science that the
dates are determined
by the fossils and the fossils are
determined by the
layers that's circular reasoning
so once your thinking has been turned
round
then you start seeing things in a
different light
and you get an understanding
which is on a direct collision cause
with the way the world thinks and this
is the problem
exactly and this is where
god in his word gives us
very clear directives
and the world does the exact
opposite it's actually um sad
because if anything that is let's say
scientific
in the bible is totally negated
through science today they say exactly
if you say something
because the bible says so they you they
think you're an idiot
now you can take any science you have
more than just
hard science you have
many sciences science of archaeology for
example
there is a science in archaeology that
is in total harmony with the bible
but secular archaeology is in direct
opposition to the bible so let's think
about that
you have darwinism which totally
negates genesis right
and you have a science that is just as
much as science
which other people would call a
conspiracy
which totally supports the bible so you
have creation science
and you have science now the scientists
will say
now excuse me creation science
in itself is a misnomer because you
can't have creation
and science it's either one or the other
and like the scientists say themselves
you cannot
allow a divine foot in the door
but what if creation is truth
then you would have to rephrase that and
say you may not
allow truth to interfere with your
science well then it's no longer science
then it's science falsely so-called
yes because if truth is truth
then you have to allow for truth to come
into
this equation yeah right 100 so
let's have a look at the broad spectrum
of the world
and ask ourselves a few questions
when it comes to creation
is there a true science and a false
science yep
yes these have the rocks changed nope
have the fossils within the rocks change
no
has the oil under the ground changed
no no none of it right
has the anatomy of the animals changed
no
no so you're still looking at the exact
same data
that's science but the way in which you
interpret them
is totally different correct
and the one is true science and the
other one is
science falsely so-called
all right let's not talk about just
the creation issue we spoke about
archaeology
is there an interpretation that
confirms the bible yes and is there an
interpretation that negates the bible
yes yes okay let's take
health health is supposed to be
thoroughly grounded in science i mean we
have a vast medical field out there
that seems to be
in the business of science right and
this is what you have to listen to
exactly
now i taught at the university i know
what that science is
because i was involved in teaching it
and even in those that i didn't teach i
was involved there
because you have to know enough so that
if someone gets sick that you take over
those classes right
yes so you are a jack of all trades and
a specialist of
one or maybe two if you're lucky
so i know what is taught at the
university level now let's take the
issue
of nutrition
the medical world out there in the
secular universities
is the so-called expert when it comes to
nutrition how much nutrition do they
get in their course probably
virtually none maybe a week or two
and then once you've studied it through
it's basically all wrong yeah okay
that's why it is so
volatile and once they say this and then
they say that
now there are scientists that do
research on these
issues and there are thousands and
thousands of publications
of true science that is done but does
that true
science necessarily filter through to
the classroom
no no it's like when you've got
it will also not filter through to the
public definitely not
so when i started discovering
the issues on health for example that
the world
is totally led up the garden path that
the original diet according to the bible
was a plant-based diet
and the world has a different diet
it's interesting to me that the world is
now talking about a plant-based
diet so it seems like you know
everything is going full circle
but even then it will be distorted
exactly
because the reasons as to why
you have to change from one to the other
are not valid right so when i started
lecturing on the health issue
i got great opposition
and eventually it took a few years
and i no longer had to defend myself
because they caught up they caught up
yes and the world was saying
more than what i was saying in the
beginning
so it's interesting that a lot of that
opposition
came from people who were supposed to be
grounded in this particular
subject and in the word of god right
yeah so if you take the health issue
you can be so manipulated by the world
that you begin to see things in the same
light as the world sees them
and then even those that are supposedly
grounded in the word of god
will run with the mainstream and we can
see it
in the world today no matter what the
science
is we're talking about so we won't go
into too many details there because we
still want to be able to talk about
these things right
so there's a true science and there is a
false science
there is a science of a philosophy of
science
which is true and there is a philosophy
of science which is
false so
let us talk about the echo
yes science that that is so prevalent in
the world today
and we have our doomsday prophets in the
eco world that are telling us
now is the time to have a total reset
or else right
so here is an article from 2019
comes from the competitive enterprise
institute
and it says wrong again
50 years of failed eco-apocalyptic
predictions it's a very interesting word
that is combining the apocalypse
which is a biblical term with the
ecology
that seems to be a very prevalent thing
in the world right
and it's leading somewhere yes
and and this is our job right that's it
to link it
to where we're heading exactly this is
this is what our job is because
you have to be watchmen on the walls of
zion
and you have to give this trumpet a
certain
sound so that people will know what is
coming
because it never comes through the front
door no
it always sneaks in via the back door
everything that's in front of you just
know
that there's something behind the scenes
also going now what's very strange to me
martin
is that so many people even within the
church
have their eyes fixed on the front door
yes
well the guy with a knife has come in by
the back door right
so we have to be very careful we have to
have
eyes all around i heard a comparison a
popular one
a magician he keeps you busy with the
one hand while the other one is doing
something else something else and that's
where the
the deception the perception you
actually shouldn't look at the hand that
is
prominent you should look at the other
one right
now when you look at the the cherubs
that are described
that are
associated with god's throne they have
eyes all around around
yeah so that's a symbolic picture
of what we should be doing we should be
looking at every angle right
and not jump onto a bandwagon just
because
it is called science beware
of science falsely so-called
could that also mean science
mis-applied and misused for a personal
agenda
yes definitely that's does that
necessarily negate the science or does
that negate their agenda
their agenda okay
so modern doomsayers have been
predicting
climate and environmental disasters
since the 1960s
and they continue to do so today one of
the experts
on these predictions is of course
the papacy none of the apocalyptic
predictions with due dates as of today
have come true now
not one now we spoke about false
prophets last time
can we talk about science falsely
so-called
yes isn't that the same thing same thing
okay
especially if they're going to link the
science to the apocalyptic right
so what follows this collection of
notably wild predictions from
notable people in government and science
more than merely spotlighting the failed
predictions this collection
shows that the makers of failed
apocalyptic predictions
often are individuals holding respected
positions in government and science
so a scientist said it yes
you better believe it better no matter
at what level
we are speaking which brings me to
another one
the science is settled they usually say
it's settled is that can that happen is
the science of evolution settled
they can settle it as much as it likes
it still looks like mud
so there are all of these failed
predictions while such predictions have
been
and continue to be enthusiastically
reported by a
media eager for sensational headlines
the failures are
typically not revisited
this is an axiom this is truth
that typically not revisited is what you
were mentioning earlier
exactly that's wrong there is some of it
that's truth
but that never falters through to the
student or the public
the same if the if it's been shown that
that wasn't true
you never see that in the headlines okay
so may i be so naughty as to
ask whether these scientists with all of
their predictions are any better than q
and on
no you're making them conspiracy
exactly well let's just go to the bible
i like to go to the bible this is worse
in genesis 1 verse 1 which says in the
beginning god created the heavens and
the earth
i mean everybody knows that verse right
it's the first verse in the bible
and it just is so
interesting that god would put it so
succinctly
so simply so straightforward
this is the way it is take it or leave
it
and humanity says let's leave it
but god says you can leave it but you're
gonna end up where you're ending up now
believing a lot of nonsense and having
to work out
hours and hours and hours of study and
millions and millions of dollars
to try and negate just that first
sentence okay let me just ask a question
how much money is spent
on furthering the theory on ev of
evolution
every single university yeah what about
cern yes that's whole
hydron collider that's built the
millions of euros that goes into that
thing
exactly but that's still science trying
to find out you know
what's going on what does everything
consist of but
on furthering a philosophy
of science how many salaries are paid
how many university institutions have
been created how many
sub-institutions furthering
basically the lie of evolution
billions and billions of dollars right
so they're not only throwing around with
billions of years they're throwing
around with
billions of dollars wasted money
in the beginning god created in the
story
and i must say if they if they took
that sentence as true
i think we would have seen so much more
breakthroughs in science they think
religion is restrictive
you know what martin when i was a
scientist
i was restricted yeah i had an interest
which was
focused on science and now
that that bubble has been burst my
interest
includes so many more things and
i can be involved in discussions of
so many more things than before
that it becomes irritating to some
people
so religion is expanding
not just restricting and then they're
always talking about
change and what's going to happen and
fear-mongering
and there will be no food there will be
no this there will be no
that and everything will become a desert
genesis 8 verse 22 while the earth
remaineth
sea time and harvest cold and heat
summer and winter day and night
shall not cease that's a promise
if you take god at its at his word
is there a reason for panic in that
verse
no no it's going to continue until the
end right
yes so the only thing that's going to
change
is the hype yes he created and he's in
control
don't deal it's very
liberating isn't it
matthew 24 37 and 38 but
as the days of noah were so shall also
the coming of the son of man be
for as in the days that were before the
flood
they were eating and drinking and
marrying and giving into marriage
until the day that noah entered the ark
so will things continue until the end
yes or no
yes so what is all the screaming about
it might be in a little bit different
way than you used to
little bit more restricted maybe a mask
on your face or so
but it will continue it will continue
until
the gray day yes so let's have a look at
some of these
interesting things that uh have been
predicted
and we don't have to go into great
detail and read every
verse over here but here's an
article from 1970 where they said
ice age by the year 2000 so there's
going to be global freezing
it's amazing that it now became global
warming right yeah so we went from
global freezing to global warming
that's why i think they changed it to
climate change yeah
so thursday april 16 1970
scientists predict a new ice age by the
21st century
air pollution may obliterate the sun
and cause a new ice age in the first
third of the next century the demands
for cooling water will
boil dry the entire flow of rivers
and streams of continental united states
everything is going to be
bone dry and a frozen desert did it come
true
no but this is scientists this is
science
and we have to listen to the science
don't we yeah
and here's another one from 1980 acid
rain
kills life in legs now there's no doubt
that
acid rain was a problem and that the ph
went down i myself gave lectures
on ecology when i was at the university
and yes this is a fact
but is it a universal phenomenon or is
it a local phenomenon
and if we just go a few years later 10
years later the us government program
formed to study acid rain concluded
acid rain no environmental crisis study
concludes
so here's a long article we're not going
to go through it
it's just they say something no they
were religious prophets what would we
say what would the bible criteria say
unfortunately you don't qualify they're
false prophets right
so can science be used as a false
prophet
yes and let's let's ask a little
more naughty question
can the real false prophet use false
science
in order to further his agenda yes
that is that's the main point that's
what it's going to
where it's heading and when we look at
all these things that happen
so here comes the science bandwagon past
you're going to going to jump on every
bandwagon that passes you by
no you're not supposed to what if they
tell you that they're going to
modify your immune system to such an
extent that your own immune system
becomes obsolete you don't need it
anymore they could get a surprise right
correct just a commercial
let's not let's not go any further than
that
in 1978 they said no end in sight
to the 30-year cooling trend
we're going to freeze to death now isn't
it interesting that in the midst of
global warming
they've had one of the coldest winters
on record in the north
right so which one was right the global
warming or the global cooling
uh well take your pick right you can't
be killed that's a coin
now what if next year is going to be a
little bit warmer what are the
scientists going to say then
it's reversed now we're going oh and now
we're back to global warming right
you have to follow the science my friend
yes
so international team of specialists
finds no end in sight to the 30-year
cooling trend
in the northern hemisphere that was in
1978.
what came of it let's have a look
here is uh and
data from nasa according to nasa
satellite data there is a slight warming
trend
since 1979. so here is their graph
and they're showing the best trend
statistically
there's the baseline and as you can see
it dips above and above and below the
baseline
and it's been increasing now this one
only goes to 2019
so you know one year later 2020 could be
very different ryan
all right so instead of a cooling trend
we had
a warming trend now some scientists
will say this warming trend is
fascinating especially if you take a
spike
and then the very next year there is
a drop right but if you concentrate all
your effort on the spike
then you could become an alarmist right
yes
so don't look at the spikes look at the
trend
yes be careful because sometimes you can
get a 10-year trend
and looking over 50 years it's a
different story yes and you have
you have many trends which run in cycles
dropped
for example wet seasons dry seasons
you have to look at the whole picture
and then we must also probably just make
it clear we're not saying there's no
manipulation going on
because the spirit of prophecy also says
that satan
is studying the laboratories yes of
nature and
man is quite capable of changing things
and seeding clouds etc etc so
we've shown that also in previously so
there can be very specific
interventions which can be interpreted
by some
in one way and by others in another
here's another 1988 prediction
james hansen forecasts increased
regional drought in the 1990s
the miami news more drought likely
expert tells senators we're going to get
drought
so what really happened but the last
really dry year in the midwest west was
in 1988
and recent years have been record wet so
we're
in a wet trend so the scientist
says we're going to be in a dry trend
now we're in a wet trend
now he was probably using
what was available and he was looking at
the peaks and he was making a prediction
and his prediction happened to be
dead wrong right yeah do we have
as we discussed last time religious
prophets
that make predictions that turn out to
be dead wrong yes
okay so is there a science that can be
falsely so-called yes so here's hansen's
forecast date
you see what happened there he was
relying
on a peak into
the dry below the norm
but then subsequently things turned
round
our climatologists
that have been speaking about global
warming have stopped speaking about
global warming
yes they're now speaking about climate
change
well let me be very predictive
i predict today as a scientist
that the winter is going to be colder
than the summer
i i think i believe you do you think you
believe but we'll have to tell everybody
but what if i predicted that the winter
is going to be warmer this year than the
summer was
then you've got a problem
so i could take a peek like that and
make a prediction
if you'd used this one i don't know
where we'd be then right we'd be in big
trouble
then james hansen's forecast increased
regional drought in 1990
prepare for long hot summers
if you like last summer's record
temperatures
you're going to love the 1990s says
james hansen's the nasa scientist
what scientist nasa isn't that
the flagship up there
absolutely right now
yeah models just for interest sake
when you are taught evolution
many many many lectures on the subject
at university
does that make it true no
no when you are taught
certain health principles
and that you have to have animal protein
in your diet and protein was the driving
force and animal protein was the better
protein because it was a complete
protein was that necessarily correct or
did it
eventually prove to be incorrect well it
proved to be incorrect
okay so many many lectures and many man
hours could have gone into trying to
substantiate
something which was at the root
false yes right how do we know that
everything we hear about cosmology is
right
we will know one day right correct do we
know where comets come from
they come out of the earth cloud has
anybody ever seen the word cloud no no
nobody's ever seen it no there's just
some some things that we'll have to wait
and see it's thumb knowledging comets
are there
therefore there must be an origin of
comets
and the man who decided that
there was an origin happened to have the
name wurt
and so it became what's cloud but
nobody's ever seen it
which means it might exist or it might
not exist
right it sounds similar to the cloud
that you store
everything on it's like that little kid
after the
the scientist had explained you know all
the issues of evolution and everything
and said everybody must believe
it because according to him you can see
it
the little kid asked him do you have a
brain
i haven't seen it i almost i know you
have one right
it didn't materialize because the very
next thing was
that things turned round so but
the number of hot days in the dc area
peaked in 1911
and have been declining ever since
so again there seems to be a cooling
and not a warming all right
and there was hansen's forecast date and
again you can see
based on a hot day and
we see this over and over and over
here's another one 1988 maldives
completely underwater
in 30 years threat to the islands
because the ocean is going to rise
because all this ice is going to flow
from greenland and from antarctica
etc right and then in 1989
rising seas to obliterate nations
by the year 2000 now this comes from the
united nations
rising seas could obliterate nations un
officials
so again we have the same kind of
prediction
this is science this is based on science
and it is a senior un
environmental official says entire
nations
could be wiped off the face of the earth
by rising sea levels
if the global warming trend is not
reversed by the year
2000 where are we now
1989 new york city
west side highway underwater by 2019
is it underwater maybe if it rains
a little bit now this is a very
interesting one
this is uh the global
mid tropospheric temperature variations
model versus observations
so this red line is the model we've
discussed this in a previous
what's up so we're not going to go back
there people can go and watch the one on
climate
and what happened over there but just
for the sake of completeness this is the
model that the
world uses and all of these trends that
you see over here
are based on models in other words they
are
gnosis they are philosophy
of science but they're not based on
reality yes
here are the actual observations
okay and there seems to be a trend
in the upward direction but if you take
this one over here which was from
2015 yeah if you go back in history to
about
1988 around about there you'll see
that that peak was higher
so we have these oscillations these are
the actual measurements
and this is a predictive trend but it
doesn't even come close
to the models and you remember al gore
with his contraption there with the lift
on it that he had to go
up into the air to show where the graph
was going to go
right through the roof yeah well nothing
came of it right
so they've been doing this for a long
time and they're no better than the
prophets that we spoke about in our last
series correct
so let's go to al gore i actually had a
lecture
about him and prince charles and the
environmental issues
which was called the beamable
sustainable princess because in actual
fact
al gore as is prince charles
are actually from royal bloodlines okay
so they're princes
and because they had themselves beamed
in a hologram
to their lecture site apparently i
called them the beamable princess
and that lecture dealt with religious
aspects as well as scientific aspects
perhaps you can put a link definitely
he's
still very active today with the climate
changes now
if we had to discuss him in the same
level
as we discussed the
[Music]
prophetic bodies and people
in the religious sphere i think we could
put him into the same category right
yep so ten years ago al gore predicted
the north polar ice cap would be gone
inconveniently it's still there
that's of course a play on on words
because he had this
this lecture the inconvenient truth yeah
you've been at a movie
yes yeah yes correct all right so that
was in 2008
when he predicted these things
and here's another one arctic sea ice
extent
area of ocean with at least 15 percent
sea ice and you can see
that it has increased
now martin they love
showing the breakdown of the glacier and
the ice falling into the sea
they love that and it is their
exhibit number one when it comes to
global warming and the effect of climate
change
on arctic ice right yeah now i remember
a movie i don't know how long
it was it was with uh
what was it flint iron man flint i think
it was
around 67 or 16. in the 60s it was
it was a american
style of james bond yes it was a james
bond type movie
of the 60s and our man flint
and in that movie there one scene there
with this ice coming crashing down
this has been going on for
millennia let alone here in these
last few years and people are overawed
my
this is really happening everything is
collapsing and of course every
generation will think
this is the case right but do they ever
look back in history
do they ever see this graph exactly
so while it crashes down on the one side
when the melt time comes in the freeze
time
it grows again on the other side so here
you have
the same type of thing and then
prince charles prince charles
now he's about the same age as i
am and he's made so many predictions
on climate and he's of course the
defender of faith
he used to be the defender of the faith
but that's gone by the wayside so in
prince charles says there are only eight
years to save the planet
so i think we're not here anymore i
think it's
it's all over right but we're still here
right
so just 96 months to save the world says
prince charles
now how many of those predictions have
we had
yeah one after the other right continues
and it varies the one gives so much the
other and these are all
highly placed people right and it's
based on
science it's based on science you have
to listen to the science
and this one's interesting in 2014
the french foreign minister said 500
days to avoid climate chaos
now i think i actually used this one in
one of my lectures
a few years ago i think so and this was
the secretary of state john kerry
welcomed french foreign minister
laurent fabius to the state department
in washington on tuesday to discuss a
range of issues from iran to syria
to climate change now john kerry as we
have shown
says that his number one priority is
climate change
now 500 days since 2014
and we still haven't had the climate
chaos
you know what this year where we are
living right now
it's been one of the best years in terms
of climate right
yeah we had beautiful temperatures
it wasn't nearly as hot as in the
previous years i could predict the
global cooling
depending on this year and we had a
wonderful rainy season yes
so i predict a global wetting
[Laughter]
this is how this is how it's going at
this stage all right
so planet's still standing 500 days
after french foreign minister warned of
climate chaos
they're a little bit tongue-in-cheek
here but this is true this is the truth
this is the way it is but the sad
point is they're still going to use it
in order to further an agenda exactly
all right so to our listeners
we're not here just pulling apart the
climate
issue the question is not
what is happening to the climate the
question
is what is it useful why is it useful
to these people to keep on
pushing this button there must be an
agenda
exactly and you if you think
we've showed now from the 60s
the prediction still 2015.
yes how many generations is that it's
about three generations
of young people that have gone through
this old time so you've
the scientists have cho there's no
person alive today that has not
um been indoctrinated with
climate change exactly just like they've
been indoctrinated with evolution
they never stop they sing the same
tune no matter what science you throw at
them
and all of those all of those i think
also in your lectures um
genesis conflict you show one after the
other
the discovery that they've said
proves evolution a few years or
months later it was shown to not be true
but that never gets through to the
public the same as this
correct so there must be a philosophy
behind all of this
so what are some of these four costs
in 1967 they said they would be dire
famine by 1975.
did it happen regionally perhaps yes
like it has been happening since the
time of abraham
joseph's the time of joseph right
1969 everyone will disappear in a cloud
of blue steam by 1999.
these are actual ones here are the
sources
1974 they said a new ice age is coming
2004 britain to have a siberian climate
by
2020. you know what they're still just
walking around with umbrellas
2008 arctic will be ice free by 2018.
did it happen no no 2009
uk prime minister says 50 days to save
the planet from catastrophe
that's a really good one 50 days
that's incredible 2009
arctic ice free by 2014
2013 arctic ice free by 2015.
you know what they bought the fiddle and
they're going to play it yeah
you must it's not going to change this
tune is going to stay
are these true prophets or are they
false prophets all qualify for false
prophets
they're false prophets but they don't
change their tune
no so they must be an agenda there must
be an agenda
now true prophets they also don't change
their tune now
but then it happens right yeah
so what do they say today that's the
next question
let's listen to the scientists well this
one is a very young scientist
but prominent enough to be able to speak
to congress
to congress and to the united nations
and to royalty the dalai lama and to the
pope himself
yes amazing
i am submitting this report as my
testimony
because i don't want you to listen to me
i want you to listen to the scientists
and i want you to unite behind the
science
and then i want you to take real action
thank you
i have a question which one of the
scientists do you want to listen to
do you think she saw what we just showed
i don't think she ever saw that she only
had a very
one-sided view of what was happening
but martin this is the state of the
world exactly
so again what is the agenda
why is it that no matter what you throw
at an evolutionary scientist
they do not change the game plan
no matter what evidence you bring in
terms of health
they do not change the game plan
no matter what evidence you bring in
terms of climate
they do not change the game plan
who's behind it who's behind the theory
of evolution
well if you go to the top to the very
source
the devil the devil
let's not ask that same question
for the others so if this task was
urgent before
this is time magazine in 2021
if this task was urgent before it's
crucial now
the u.n says the world has 10 months to
get serious
on climate goals this is tedious
before you read i just want to maybe
remind the viewers
that since 1965 or whatever when we
showed now
has there been laws implemented
because of climate change absolutely
based on what
based on and we see all this false
narratives and where are we going
they're still
saying it are we going to see law still
implemented
all right so they said 500 days
the prime minister said 50 days some
said 10 months
and now we're in 2021
and they're saying 10 months and people
believe
it they believe it the world believes us
yes
one thing that's that's really um
escalated through this time is how
everybody has started to believe this if
you repeat
something over and over again eventually
people come to believe it
now john kerry and joe biden have made
it quite clear
that this is point number one on their
agenda and you mentioned somebody else
who is it also his top priority the pope
the pope
okay so the pope has the agenda and the
powerful
governments of the world have the agenda
and the predictions are exactly the same
as they were
decades ago nothing has changed
so the world has precisely 10 months to
get our act together
if there is to be any hope of staving
off a climate catastrophe
by the end of the century so now we have
to
get moving they've sung the tune
and everybody knows the melody now this
is a bit tongue-in-cheek
it says that nature
still sets the example never trust
a greenie you have a green frog in this
little mouse
and eventually it'll swallow you up well
basically this is joking but there is an
element of truth in it right
now martin is it only the scientists
or is the religious world involved in
this oh
it is crazy what's happening now what
did what did that first verse talk about
timothy timothy i would like to say
martin martin
be careful be very careful of science
falsely so-called and he was talking in
a religious
connotation right yes now
when you combine this science with
religion
then you are striking not
just at the physical level but at the
moral level yes so here you have
the parliament of world religions
and it speaks about green faith
what's the story with that frog yeah
became careful if it's green right
day of action march 11 2021
that's come and gone sacred people
sacred earth is organized by green
faith and the parliament of the world's
religions is proud to
join communities and organizations
around the world
in serving as a co-sponsor
so now you've joined science and
religion
and the parliament of world religion
represents
all the religions of the world and it
speaks about
sacred people sacred earth
this is earth worship number one this is
gaia worship and sacred people this
sounds like korra
everybody is holy everybody is holy what
happened to korra by the way
okay now what does green faith have to
say that is associated with
the parliament of world religions
mission
because the earth and all people are
sacred and at risk
green faith is building a worldwide
multi-faith climate and environmental
movement our vision
we envision a world transformed in which
humanity
in all its diversity has developed a
shared
reverence for life on earth religious
and spiritual communities everywhere
generate
a moral awakening to the sacredness of
earth
and the dignity of all people immoral
are we heading somewhere oh definitely
theory of change around the globe
we are organizing people of faith
spiritually but
not religious people and religious
leaders to join the green faith
community and to develop
local circles
it's a very occult principle the circles
yes
there's also in christianity the
spiritual
the spiritual formation it's auroborus
the serpent with his tail in the mouth
we won't stop until equitable
self-sustainable policies actions and
practices
are embodied at every level all right
let's just
get back to basics have you
any concept of what the primary function
of religion is
for example christianity the primary
function
is to get well jesus said make disciples
and
tell the whole world about the good news
and what is the good news
the gospel of salvation that's the
primary function
uh do you see that primary function
anywhere over here
all right the bible has a lot to say
that about environment as well that god
will deal with people that hurt the
earth etc
and that disregard life on earth and
take it for granted yes there are issues
at that but the primary function
is to preach the gospel and this is
totally
out of the equation and then they have
ten demands does that sound
like uh ten commandments yep
it's interesting that they have ten
demands i'm very allergic to the word
demand
i always tell the story about when the
the students
burst into my office one day and
they shouted at me we demand
that was a very mundane issue something
as
simple as there weren't enough
facilities in the washrooms toilet paper
was
one of the problems it seems like toilet
paper is much in the news these days
right
on an environmental scale now
but that was the issue and
you know when the role is finished
there's nothing else why can't there be
some more over there so
they burst in and they said we demand
i i let them steam a little while and
ask them what happened to the good
old-fashioned request
and we discussed it and i said you know
that's very reasonable
i'm sure we can arrange something like
that and
it was arranged but here you have 10
demands
100 renewable clean energy for all
interesting so that puts an end to any
form
of fossil fuel usage or whatever
finance global finance aligned with
compassionate values
yes that one sounds like the religious
agenda the agenda and the previous one
the political agenda correct
employment jobs and health care for all
now if you take our country what is the
unemployment rate
40 i think yeah and if you take the
youth into account it's probably
in the region of 50 right so how are you
going to employ them
what if you reduced the hours
of work and doubled up the teams
could you solve that you probably could
right
self-determination respect indigenous
rights
welcome for migrants
no more climate pollution end the
planet's
desecration eliminate immortal
investment
and they will have to start with
themselves right
climate reparations from wealthy
countries
that's an interesting one martin climate
reparations from
wealthy countries now the wealthiest
countries
on the world seem to me to have the
greatest debt in the world
are they therefore wealthy or are they
bankrupt they're bankrupt
so how do bankrupt nations repair
everything
bold faith community leadership
so those are the ten demands
the new ten commandments is there
anything there
about salvation no and just another
point
you might know somebody might now say
but you know
who's who are these guys the green faith
but i hope that they've
realized those 10 demands
you hear it now in the political and
religious sphere
exactly and the spokespersons for them
are of the highest level in the united
nations
and in the religious world
so let's go to one of those
spokespersons
pope calls for a new world order now
this is march 15 2021
he's been calling for this new world
order for a long time
and the politicians have been calling
for this new world order and the united
nations has been calling for this new
world order and the parliament of world
religions has been calling for this
new world order so the pope
calls for a new world order let's say
there once again
and says that wasting the covet crisis
would be worse than the
pandemic in other words wasting a good
opportunity a good crisis
a good crisis in language apparently
drawn from the globalist playbook the
pope called for a new world order
built upon his concept of solidarity
which in
turn is drawn from his comments and
publication
on irreligious fraternity
francis also copied the phraseology of
globalist
leaders by mentioning how the covet
crisis
should not be wasted let us all
keep in mind that there is something
worse than the crisis
the drama of wasting it
we cannot emerge from a crisis the same
as before
we either come out better or we come
out worse he called the covet pandemic
an alarm signal on which humanity is
forced to reflect
referring to the cornerstones of
reconstruction
which would be a key part of his new
world order the time of trial can thus
become a time of wise
and far-sighted choices for the good of
humanity
of all humanity he added
who defines this good he does right he
does
and then he calls it common yes it's
actually his good
but he calls it common who says that
he's good is my good
he says he says and because he's the
pope
it better be my good right yeah it's for
the common
but if it's not according to his then
there's a problem
in fact the pope even linked the
theological aspect of
salvation to the promotion
of a new world order in line with
globalist policies
suggesting that salvation was dependent
upon their success
that is a form of universalism correct
correct and you better be on that
bandwagon
[Music]
should his words be ignored the pope
warned there would be no future for
anyone
and thus the world must prepare for
tomorrow under the banner of human
fraternity
since there is no alternative
who defines that once again him
are there riots in the world because of
the changes that have taken place
yes so there are many many people in the
world
millions yeah who are unhappy correct
right but there's no alternative no
who has decided that him he
yes he has decided that he's linked to
salvation
yeah it's scary don't don't get all
worked out
relax no it's bad if you think about
this
if you think about it it's actually
and it's not gonna go away
if we don't roll up our sleeves and
immediately take care of the earth with
radical personal and political choices
with an economic
green turn by directing technological
developments in this direction sooner or
later our common home
will be have thrown us out the window
stated francis we cannot waste any more
time
reminds me of that frog that greeny
that greeny you might just be
ready to swallow you is it not
interesting
how the we saw that climate scientists
predicting everything and now you've got
the pope
and kerry and all of this religion
coming into this as well now
and where is heading but what are we
interested in
again yes where is it heading what's the
agenda right
so here is desert news from march
2021 another way to go
green many organizations that operate
daily are setting goals to be more
socially responsible by going green
and reducing their carbon footprint
what if there was an easier and faster
way to do this
what if an organization that operates
every day could reduce its
emissions by 14.2 percent of the bat
the answer close operations
for one day a week can encourage
employees to take the day
off now let's just talk about carbon
dioxide
the carbon dioxide cycle is a natural
cycle
in the world and any excess
carbon dioxide will be
absorbed in the carbon dioxide
sink which is basically
the ocean to a great extent and most of
the world
consists of ocean so we have a vast
carbon dioxide
sink and carbon dioxide
that i breathe out is the very food
of the plant world
that is in turn going to give me the
oxygen
that i need so these are cycles that
have been built
in by a very wise
architect right
so god himself built these cycles into
nature
so who is the recipient of the carbon
dioxide that i produce
the plants of the plant what would be
the most
logical way to solve an excess
of carbon dioxide plant more trees more
plants plant trees
correct of course it isn't anything new
in addition to the sabbath days the jews
have another
observance called shemitah where they
let the land
rest for a year which will start
this coming september while there are
different reasons why this practice was
introduced long ago the principles can
be applied for our benefit today
companies will be concerned about losing
all the business that comes by staying
open on sundays but what is the price
they are willing to pay to help protect
the environment
so is there an agenda yes is there a
solution and have they again mix the
sabbath day
up with the sunday yes they always do
that right
it's like an evolutionist he keeps on
singing the same tune
even though it's basically flawed right
so let's look at again i know we've done
this in the last one as well
but we've got to get the point across
that there is an agenda
sunday should be made rest with family
so the issue of rest for the earth rest
for humanity becomes very
important but the fact
that it was set aside for holy use
for communion with god has been switched
to communion with nature
and communion with the family alone
and with the sporting world
so kuala lumpur women family and
community development deputy minister
proposed that sunday be made a rest with
family day
so just another example in serbia
trade unions urge ban on working
on sundays now when you go
into the history of trade unions martin
where did they originate isn't it also
the papacy
in the vatican it seems as if all
roads lead to rome you know what
when i became an adventist my i couldn't
believe
my eyes when i started seeing this trend
everything for the past six years that
i've studied
goes back to rome everything goes back
to rome
so trade unions are going to be involved
because
they are going to be the driving force
to make sure that sunday is implemented
can they become very radical
have we experience in our own country of
how radical they can become
yeah the representatives of the ministry
of economy have told us
that if the surveys conducted indicate
that retailers are strongly opposed to
our idea
then other options will have to be
considered for example
a ban on working on sundays in the first
or last week of the month
which would be the first step to accept
the ban
on working every sunday afterwards
so safik said right
the union won't give up on this idea
we wouldn't be happy if the ban is only
applicable
to one or two sundays a month but
also there's still no reason to reject
it
savik said well he is the representative
of this trade union
all right so the trade unions are going
to enforce it now some countries like
croatia
already introduced the once a month
issue
yes then it was to become twice a month
and eventually it should be
every single sunday so the countries
have been
incrementally introducing it
slowly and it's worldwide worldwide
we've gone from the philippines
or to kuala lumpur to serbia croatia
which if you go and watch the previous
episodes you'll find a trend that
goes all the way there's almost not a
country that's not showing this yet
now what does the spirit of prophecy
have to say
and the trade unions will be one of the
agencies that will bring upon this earth
a time of trouble
such as not been seen since the world
began
the trade unions are going to be part
and parcel
of end time events one of the means not
the only one but one of it
god has revealed what is to take place
in the last days that his people may be
prepared to stand against the tempest of
opposition and wrath
those who have been warned of the events
before them
are not to sit in calm expectation
of the coming storm comforting
themselves that the lord will
shelter his faithful ones in the day of
trouble
you know modern there are so many people
even within our own ranks
that say why are you always talking
about these things why are you warning
just relax
god will take care of it no here's a
solemn warning
correct don't sit on your leaves
and think that you can get by without
saying anything
or considering the matter in terms of
your own
actions we are to be
as men waiting for their lord not in
idle
expectancy but in earnest work with
unwavering faith now what is that work
warning people yeah yeah sounding their
lawn
sounding the alarm
it is no time now to allow our minds to
be engrossed with things of minor
importance while men
are sleeping this is the back door
experience
right satan is actively arranging
matters so that the lord's people may
not
have mercy or justice
are god's people being maligned at the
moment
are they called cults yes conspiracy
theorists and are there people in our
own ranks that give
these labels extremist
fundamentalists that are actually
preaching these things
correct i i would say that these people
should
read what it says here right
so while men are sleeping satan is
actively arranging matter so that the
lord's people may not have mercy or
justice
the sunday movement is now making its
way
in darkness the leaders are concealing
the true issue
and many unite in the movement do not
themselves
see whether the undercurrent is tending
they're looking at the science looking
at the signs joining in ecumenism
and joining trade unions thinking that
they're doing a good thing
its professions are mild and apparently
christian when it comes from the
religious side
but when it shall speak it will reveal
the spirit of the dragon
that's the agenda that last sentence
that you read
makes me think of the article that you
read of the pope
exactly sneaking it in there
and pretending that this is to
save humanity for your salvation
when it will lead to perdition
here's an article regarding the
philippines and again here they're
saying
that the covet 19 just like the pope
was now a a perfect
situation to bring about some changes
and what are they talking about closing
on sunday yes didn't we
and i'm sure you can go and watch of our
earliest episodes we said
they will use the lockdown strategies
and all of this
to eventually come to sunday lockdowns
correct they're going to
show back to it and say but it worked
for covet
so so we made that prediction we haven't
changed our tune
and here we can see that people are
starting to call for this
perhaps the government should rethink
and reimpose the blue
sunday laws so it talks about his
youth and what it was like and we should
go back
the only difference is that this is now
on a universal scale yes
all different countries and this one is
new
this is turkey so now you have an
islamic
country and this is very interesting
because people say
well what is the islamic world going to
do they're going to climb on the
bandwagon
because remember we said it had to be
synchronized
free time that means everybody
must keep the same day
the sunday debate in turkish retail
industry has reignited as trades people
reiterated calls for shopping malls and
grocery store chains
to remain closed on the last day of the
week again they're confused
but babylon stands for confusion
correct it's not the last day of the
week it's the first day of the week
so turkish tradesmen and craftsman
tes k chair person so and so recently
said
that they want arrangements to be made
to protect tradespeople
in the new draft law so islamic
countries are
on board yep they're on board
someone this one here from salon march
2021 is a very very interesting article
because now they're going to take
everything that has maligned
as malicious in the world
will be linked to a particular religious
stream
so you can pull the plug on them and
that's what we just read in that
statement
in the spirit of prophecy that matters
will be put in a certain light
so that god's people will be maligned
and persecuted
right let's have a look they start off
with q anon
it's their favorite little buzz word at
the moment
is also much more than a mere conspiracy
theory
it is a cult that has destroyed families
and relationships
it is a con that lures in the
weak-minded
and the vulnerable now martin what could
we link that to
could we link this dastardly
organization or thinking pattern to a
religious pattern
yes and it's also interesting that
just as we had scientists up until now
now we've got religion
expert writing this so here we have a
religious experts
we have so many experts in the world
right
so now let's see who he links it to cue
anon
also has elements of religion
adriana la france writes at the atlantic
the seventh day
adventists and the church of jesus
christ of latter-day
saints are thriving religious movements
indigenous to america
do not be surprised if q anon becomes
another
it already has more adherence by far
than either of these two denominations
had in the first decades of their
existence
now why mention those two
why is it just grabbing them out of a
hat or is there an agenda that's an
agenda there's definitely a plan because
like we saw in the previous ones
it's we also actually referred to this
specific article that
that le france wrote yeah we referred to
that last
but this guy now this expert
is showing that and bringing
all sorts of things back to the
conspiracy side of kiernan but
pulling the religion of the seventh
adventist in
there correct but one thing that's very
interesting here
to me if you take these two religious
bodies that they have
highlighted here the seventh-day
adventists
and then the mormons
the mormons are
universal to an extent but they are
basically concentrated in one state in
the united states of america right
utah that's where they have their base
so they are very local with
some universal ramifications what about
the seventh-day adventists
universal they're universal they're in
every
nation so when legislation
sunday legislation is introduced will it
affect the mormons
no no because they keep sunday in any
case
will it affect the seventh day
adventists yes only regionally or
universally
universally this is the issue
that's why the remnant
has to be in every tribe and nation and
people
because it has to be a universal body
right
and the message of the seventh day
adventists
is a universal message saying with a
loud voice
to every nation tribe and people
fear god and give glory to him for the
hour of his judgment has come and then
follows the three angels messages
so who's the real enemy in the
eyes of the powers that be
they that keep the commandments of god
and have the testimony of jesus correct
because if they have the testimony of
jesus
then they believe the bible correct and
if they believe the bible
then they are at loggerheads with
science falsely so-called not with
science
but with science falsely
so-called here's an article in newsweek
global march 20 anti-vaccine
protests promoted by q a non-linked
groups
so now they're bringing in uh
the vaccination issue everything if
anybody is
now having a demonstration around the
world anti-something or against
something
they are going to be linked to q anon
and then q1 will be compared to
the seventh adventist the seventh there
they're dragging all so the links
are now out there so we have an octopus
out there yes
and it has all these tentacles and he's
taking
all of the issues and eventually
everything that's bad and evil in the
world
will be linked to the seventh-day
adventists okay
so the worldwide rally for freedom and
democracy events on march 20 are being
widely promoted online
with rallies against coronavirus
restrictions and the tyranny
of the vaccine implementation taking
place in countries such as the us
australia canada japan germany
a channel on encrypted messaging service
app telegram promoting the anti-vaccine
events across the world currently has
more than 35 000
subscribers and this is going to be
linked to
q and r they even mentioned that well
it's not specifically q anon that's
organizing this
there's enough of their supporters that
support this
so now it's a q anon thing so if there
is one voice
then that's good enough for them they
can just as well now say
because they are organizing these
rallies
the seventh adventists also support us
so if there were a seventh day
adventist among them amongst the 35 000
then it would be a seventh day advent
australia right that's how the news is
going to portray everything
that's how they're going to do it it's
very clever
so let's sum this up daniel 12
1 and at that time referring
to the last events on this earth
shall michael stand up
now we need to still talk a lot about
michael right
the name actually means he who is what
god
is the great prince which stands for the
children of thy people and there shall
be
a time of trouble such as never was
since there was a nation even to that
same time now this time of trouble
martin
will be when the plagues fall
upon this earth there will come a time
of trouble
such as never was and mankind will have
brought it upon itself
by making void god's law
and implementing human
inventions and the religious world led
by the papacy
is the driving force behind this
but the promise is and at that time
thy people shall be delivered every one
that shall be
found written in the book which book
will that be
the book of life that'll be the book of
life
so if we can sum this up
sea time and harvest will continue
until the end people will be living
as they did in the days of noah
marrying and giving into marriage life
will continue
it will be hard and it will get harder
it's called the little time of trouble
which i believe
we are in and then
it will culminate in
a time of trouble such as never was
and i believe that that
is at the door even
at the door when you see
standing in the holy place the
abomination
of desolation spoken of by the prophet
daniel
then i believe i can see the abomination
of desolation
standing all around the holy place
preparing for a
final attack and may god be with us
when that day arrives let's pray
heavenly father
we are seeing the fulfillment of
prophecy before our eyes
working in darkness the enemy
is planning his strategy
but he's planning it lord in such a way
that even the elect
want to climb onto the bandwagon
and even go further assist him
in his activities
preserve us from his delusions
and help us to walk in the light
is my prayer in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe
click here when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here thank you